what was
uh president xi saying yesterday
we were talking mostly about the the
virus
and i think he's going to have it in
good shape but you know it's a very
tricky situation
it's uh it goes it goes through air bob
that's always tougher than the touch you
know the touch you don't have to touch
things right but the air
you just breathe the air and that's how
it's passed
and so that's a very tricky one that's a
very delicate one
uh it's also more deadly than your you
know
your even your strenuous flus you know
people don't realize we lose 25 000 30
000 people a year here
who would ever think that right i know
that's pretty amazing
and then i say well is that the same
thing for
this is more deadly this is five per
you know this is five percent versus one
percent and less than one percent
you know so this is deadly stuff
president trump there talking to bob
woodward about the pandemic back
early in early february saying that he
knew
that the coronavirus was deadly but
wanted to
downplay it joe biden and other
democrats jumping on that news
but the president hit back yesterday
calling woodward's new book
a political hit job vice president mike
pence
is today's headliner and joins us now mr
vice president good morning thank you
for being here
good morning sandra good to be with you
so the president in his defense
of these audio tapes has basically said
this is
this was a strategy on his part to
prevent panic
to bring calm to the american people so
if it was a strategy is it one that you
know
you knew of mr vice president what i saw
firsthand from that day in january in
the oval office
when president trump took the
unprecedented step
of suspending all travel from china
declaring a public
a health emergency is that this
president to put the health
of america first from day one
but he also wanted to reassure the
american people all along
the way there's that old saying from
world war ii
in great britain that keep calm carry on
and
that was the presidential leadership
that i saw but
when you look at the fact that joe biden
democrats and even the world health
organization
criticized the president's decision to
suspend all travel from china
it took place a week before that audio
clip that you just played
and when you see that it was in in march
the other audio clip that's getting a
lot of coverage
uh is from march 19th where the
president spoke about his
desire to to create a tone to prevent
panic sandra it's important to remember
that the president made that comment
four days after we shut down the entire
american economy to put the health of
america first
and so look from from the moment he
tasked the
me to lead the white house coronavirus
task force the president made it clear
he wanted us to deploy the full
resources of the federal government
the a whole of america approach
and the progress that we have made i
believe has literally saved
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
lives but
all along the way what the american
people saw was a president who was
projecting the kind of of leadership the
kind of confidence in the american
people and all of our health care
experts and our doctors and nurses that
you would just expect from a president
in a challenging time like this mr vice
president to your point um our producers
put together
some of those various moments that
followed these audio tapes of the
president
putting out this calm to the american
people as the pandemic was really
setting in listen
i think it's going to all work out fine
rough stuff i tell you rough rough stuff
but i think it's going to work out
people have to remain calm i want to
keep the country calm
i don't want panic in the country i
could cause panic much better than even
you
but mr vice president you rewind to
february 7th
and you hear him on that tape saying
this is deadly stuff
more deadly than your strenuous flu on
tape talking about
just how contagious this virus it is it
can spread through
air and then in the weeks that followed
publicly at a new hampshire rally
telling the american people it's going
to be fine february 26th the white house
coronavirus task force
meeting saying that it's possible that
the case number will go to zero
comparing it to the flu
twice he talked about calm but he also
told the american people
it's going to go away so the question is
with the president's strategy to
in your words and the presidents to
bring this calm did he harm the ability
to stop the spread of this
virus by not warning the american people
what he knew were the dangers of it
absolutely not sandra i mean look again
i want to go back
joe biden the democrats and the world
health organization
criticized the president's decision to
suspend all travel
from china in early february we were
hearing tell
uh about about this respiratory illness
that was spreading across
wuhan and so the president put the
health of the american people first in
that first week of february we started
work on a vaccine
and in six short weeks we already were
in clinical trials
for a coronavirus vaccine and we believe
that we're well on our way to having a
coronavirus
vaccine in record time before the end of
this year
all along the way assessing supplies
assessing
logistics uh and and when we came to
that moment
uh on march 15th the president announced
that
first of 15 days to slow the spread it
would become 45 days to slow
the spread all along the way the
president's mandate was that we would
spare no expense we would put the health
of america first
despite the criticism that he endured i
mean you need to remember
too sandra that um on on the last day of
february there were roughly
15 domestic cases of coronavirus in
america
and a month earlier the president
suspended all travel from china
under a hailstorm of criticism from joe
biden
and the left two weeks later we would
suspend
essentially much of the american economy
to put the health of our country first
we reinvented testing
now we're doing more than 800 000 tests
a day we saw to the
distribution in the manufacture of
hundreds of
millions of supplies of ppe and new
medicines i couldn't be more proud of
the response of the american people
more proud of the response of health
officials in every agency of government
states across the country and i couldn't
be more proud of the strong
steady leadership that president donald
trump
brought to this coronavirus pandemic
from day one and i should acknowledge
that dr
fauci was interviewed after the
revelation of these tapes and he said
he didn't see a disparity on what the
president was telling him
and what he was telling the public and
what he was doing mr vice president
but do you sandra that's exactly right
and let me let me help you with that
and you know i've worked with dr fauci
every step
of the way in this and all of our health
experts i mean when dr fauci said
yesterday that
everything that our health experts told
the president in the oval office
he went out and told the american people
and so i believe what the president was
speaking about
uh with uh with bob woodward on march
19th was just the tone
that he was projecting i mean this this
is a president who believes
that that a president of the united
states in such moments needs to project
strength you can't project weakness but
there's a difference mr vice president
that we will together get through this
and so
his tone was one of projecting calm
and confidence but i heard him at that
podium i heard him in every setting we
gave the american people the facts
and i literally believe that the
president's decision to suspend travel
to china
the largest mobilization since world war
ii
i mean and and asking the american
people to shut down our economy for 45
days to slow the spread to save lives is
exactly the kind of presidential
leadership that the american people hope
for and pray for
in times like this i appreciate that
answer that what's being debated though
while we all taken these audio tapes is
whether it was misinformation to the
american public
when you consider that the president
knew how deadly it was
more deadly than a strenuous flu in his
own words but then went on in public
environments to discuss it
and compare it to the flu i'll let you
respond to that in a second but robert
o'brien the national security advisor to
the president
he confirmed that in late january at an
intelligence briefing told the president
warned the president that this would be
the biggest national security threat
that he would face during his presidency
were you privy to that same information
that day did you receive that briefing
mr vice president
i was in the oval office the day that
the team came in and briefed
the president about what we perceived
was happening
in china remember the world health
organization failed as china was not
forthcoming
with the united states about what was
happening there but the team
came in and laid the facts that as we
knew them
on the table to the president and again
i have to tell you to see the president
sit behind
the resolute desk in the oval office and
do what no american president had ever
done
and that was suspend all travel from
china
to me was it was a a historic example of
presidential leadership
and it saved hundreds of thousands if
not millions
of lives but the truth is we were
learning all along the way
i mean on this network on other networks
you had health experts our own health
experts
were not yet convinced about the the
level of contagion or how serious it was
i think dr fauci often speaks eloquently
about the fog of
war and and and when i stepped into the
white house coronavirus task force
leadership at the end of february again
we had we only had 15
cases of coronavirus domestic in the
united states and i
the first case of community transmission
also happened at the very end of
february so look the you know
hindsight is 2020 recriminations
what the president was communicating i
believe what you hear in that february
tape
uh was was the seriousness with which he
took this from
day one on that note again i i think
your viewers deserve to know that when
the president made the comment about
down playing
on march 19th that was four days after
this president ordered us to shut down
the entire american economy
to put the health of america first on
that note
he did speak to bob woodward in 18
different interviews for nine hours the
president's chief of staff mark meadows
on fox news last night
said that's not something he would have
recommended had he been in the role at
that time did you know that he was
talking to bob woodward
18 different times for nine hours
i ran into bob woodward i think once in
the white house i wasn't aware of a
number of times
the president spoke to him but look uh
sandra you know i i don't know there's
ever been a more accessible
president of the united states than
president donald trump was that a good
idea whether he's walking to the
airplane walk into the helicopter
whether it's
press briefings this president has been
straight with the american people
and i think when you look at the way
he's led through this pandemic
that's also been true i mean honestly
tony fauci put it so well yesterday
when he said everything that our health
experts told the president in the oval
office
he told the american people okay and
and it's important that people
understand that that's what i saw as
well i actually didn't
sense the president was downplaying
anything we were giving the american
people the facts as we knew them as we
learned them
every step of the way and the american
people are incredible doctors and nurses
health officials in states across the
country and all across the federal
government
responded with incredible
professionalism respectfully mr vice
president
but it's so important in moments like
this that the president of the united
states project confidence to the
american people that they understand
that that we were deploying the full
resources of the federal government
calling forth the full power of of the
american economy to meet this moment
and i and i promise you sandra we're
going to continue to do that every step
of the way
until until we have a coronavirus
vaccine and we put this pandemic in the
past once and for all
okay we have a lot more to get to if i
could ask you about the wildfires that
are raging out on the west coast
three states affected uh seeing seven
deaths now one
involving a small child what can you
tell us is being done at the federal
level now to step in and help as these
fires are still raging well we're
working very closely with
governors in in states that are affected
i think when
governor gavin newsom submitted a
disaster declaration president trump
approved that
in roughly 24 hours we've issued 22
separate federal fire support
grants and we've already got resources
by the millions of dollars that are
flowing to impacted families but look
my daughter and son-in-law live in
california
our hearts go out to all of those that
are enduring
or threatened by these fires and i want
to assure everyone that we're going to
make sure that those courageous
firefighters
that homeowners and businesses have the
full support of the federal government
as we
as we make our way through uh through
these fires but but also as we
as we make our way through what is just
actually the beginning of uh
of the fire season out west amazing to
see those orange skies when we were
showing pictures of san
francisco and such an enormous task for
those on the ground that are fighting
these flames
i want to move on now to you on the
ground in pennsylvania yesterday mr vice
president
pennsylvania obviously a key state in
the upcoming election a state that the
kerry
president carried in 2016. he's behind
in the real clear politics
average of polls in that state right now
obviously you were there
on the ground trying to sway voters with
your yours in the president's law and
order message message
on the economy what are you doing as you
work your way towards
your big debate october 7th with kamala
harris what is the strategy to win over
voters in a state like pennsylvania
well we're just going to go out and talk
about the fact that this president has
literally kept more promises
than he made to the people of
pennsylvania he said we're going to
rebuild our military
we're going to revive the economy with
less taxes less regulation more free and
fair
trade and more american energy and that
we were going to stand by our most
cherished values including the right to
life and yesterday in pennsylvania
we celebrated this president's uh
nomination to more than 200
strong conservatives to our federal
courts including two supreme court
justices president trump's strong stand
for the right to life which resonates
with people all across the heartland
including pennsylvania
but the message that that i drove home
yesterday literally standing
uh at a drilling site in pennsylvania is
president donald trump promised that we
would unleash american
energy we've done just that for the
first time
in 70 years we're a net exporter of
energy but but joe biden and kamala
harris
actually have talked about abolishing
fossil fuels
and i know joe biden now he went to
pittsburgh and said that he's
he's not banning fracking but that's at
odds with
everything that he has said for the last
year he he told one supporter i
guarantee i guarantee uh that we will
abolish fossil fuels he said in a debate
that even if it costs hundreds of
thousands of american
jobs that there would be no place for
fracking or fossil fuels
in his administration and based on the
enthusiasm i saw on that
particularly hot day yesterday in
freedom pennsylvania
is that the people of pennsylvania are
getting the message they know it
that they voted for a president who was
committed
to a strong military to law and order at
home to a growing economy to more
american energy
to traditional values and they know the
choice in this election could not be
more clear and i think
people of pennsylvania are going to vote
for four more years for president donald
trump
in the white house mr vice president
we're out of time it was great to have
you here in america's newsroom really
appreciate your time this morning
thank you sandra thank you